It's also worth bearing in mind what this course is not about. The course is not
an introduction to networking, so there are a
number of basic topics that won't be covered in
this course. In particular, we'll assume that you're
already familiar with the basics of things like TCP,
Socket programming, and so forth. Anything that you
might have picked up in an introductory networking course.
We are just going to assume as a
prerequisite for this course. So before you proceed,
it may be worth revisiting some of
your old undergraduate networking course material. The course
is also not providing any introduction to
programming. However, many assignments in the course will
make use of some amount of programming. So,
some knowledge of scripting languages like Ruby, Python
or Perl will certainly be helpful in some assignments.
We'll be making a lot of use of a
network emulation toolkit called Mininet and to use that
tool most effectively, You will certainly want to learn
some Python if you don't already know it. Don't
worry if you don't know these languages already though.
There's plenty of time to learn, in the course.
Since the deadlines are fairly spread out, and the assignments
aren't focused on knowledge of programming per say. But rather, the
concepts that you are going to realize in the programming languages.